the game was equal throughout but a gift
given at the very end as rita you
couldn't have suspected that she would
play a move like queen to f3 allowing
rook to e3 the game seems even
throughout
yeah the game seemed pretty even
although she seemed to think a lot so i
thought she was under pressure and when
she went into this two rooks versus
queen
i thought you know i thought i had to
mess i mean like make the position a
little messy like on not like with the
queen and rokai because i thought she
can play that very easily so i did did
it this way and then when she started to
think before playing queen f3 i kind of
figured she was going for that because
it's easy to miss rookie 3 when she was
running low on time but
it was very lucky
fortunate deed uh that's not one she's
gonna be happy about no way in the world
your tournament did end on a high note
it looks like
yeah after winning after losing three
games and i was able to win the last two
so that's definitely feels good what do
you feel about the tournament overall
it's been a roller coaster of a
tournament from starting well within
three losses but i think overall given
circumstances i think i got the most
points i could what are the lessons that
you're going to take away from this
event
probably to play a little slower as well
as to focus on stamina that one game
that i lost i got a bit careless near
the end
anything in the opening
middle game play anything there to
improve if you're going to try to win a
title
i think middle game probably a little
better i think my opening preparation
for most games were fine um except a
couple so probably improve their like
expand my repertoire
all right well we wish you the best and
see you next year thank you
uh congratulations to sharitha i know
those rollercoaster rides where you're
winning and losing and winning and
losing and you